who's the guy who did like that who or
who is doing the massive question okay i
was gonna get outside
oh yeah yeah that's uh that's genus uh
gino samuel 2.1 he lives in he lives in
japan
do you want to explain that because okay
showed us this the other day
we'll talk about we'll talk we'll go to
jail back in some other channels so
there's this channel called gino samuel
2.1 and like
he his whole channel is dedicated to uh
the history of christian you know who
chris chan is he's very very
uh infamous online and the whole point
of if you know what kiwi farms is is a
[ __ ] talking website
that whole that whole website was made
to document chris
because there's so much information
about this one person online he's
probably
the most documented person in history
yeah that's
like it's it's kind of like i mean we
watched what like
two episodes so out of how many episodes
which was like how how long were the
episodes like 40 minutes 40 minutes at
least
so we watched an hour and a half of like
this
this prologue not even the [ __ ]
prologue and the amount of
information they got about this guy's
life was just [ __ ] mind-blowing i'm
like age
five from age five so his whole channel
is dedicated to discussing chris chan
and
you're probably thinking like there
can't be that much on this dude like
they've made like biopics about some of
the most interesting people and they're
only two hours long right yeah
we're on like part like it's something
near 50 or
on 50. and the reason why channels
called like 2.1 is because i've been
watching this since like episode five
right um his channel got like taken down
at one point right episode like 15 or
something
and he decided to quit talking about it
i don't know what happened
right because he he got out he came back
he came
he just when i thought i was out they
pull me back here
he's back he's back doing it now anyway
i i don't know how far we are into it
but all the comments and actually chris
chan replies to every single video
really really really in like tries to
correct details
there's an even question about the fact
that he's making
christian seems to like it sorry i think
it's she now um so i'm sorry for dead
naming but um yeah it's really
interesting and i hope that you
keep finishing the thing and get to the
end yeah because
i don't even want to know how much the
mental told that how far are we through
chris chan's life right now i think
maybe maybe halfway
i'm not sure and how much like how many
hours of content do you think has
been made about 30 plus at the moment
yeah let's do the math if like each
episode is at least 30 minutes and it's
like
there was like at least 25. 15 episodes
so just like
christian being trolled well i mean i
mean when we when you showed us that
yeah at your place we watched the first
two episodes yeah and we hadn't even
made it past age 10. i mean the majority
of the videos have been about trolling
with chris chan
yeah yeah good chance that they might
reply to here but i mean it's super
interesting and if you want to
it's so bad as well because uh chris
chan is like autistic and constantly
says it constantly says high functioning
autism
yeah and then documentary and like you
kind of like in the start you really
want to root for him because yeah
you know he's clearly just been it's
that life yeah right and like
you know parents in it as well are like
super questionable
and then the moment you're about to root
for him he's just like i don't like gays
i think that blacks are like less than
people and it's like god [ __ ] damn
yeah yeah
he literally had us in the first half
and then it's like god damn it man
you're so close because it's like it's
like the thai king documentary right
like
they they want you to root for joe
exotic but they know about all the
racist [ __ ] that joe was saying right
yeah yeah i don't think i would have
rooted
yeah i mean it's like it's just good
storytelling right because
what i find like [ __ ] terrifying
about the first two
episodes of this documentary that i
watched just the sheer the sheer amount
of information and like just the sheer
amount of intimate information that
i probably wouldn't even know about my
own life at that age
let alone someone else's life so
christian
the one of the first things that opened
up open wide like the whole trolling
thing is that uh
when it was all started in the correct
i'm sure the comments will correct me if
i'm wrong i need these details because
people are all like historians about him
yeah i think they're called christopher
christopher is what they call themselves
so
i love that internet for historians when
when they first started the
dramatica threat about him yeah yeah the
first thing that chris did
was correct it well correct it by
overloading it with personal information
thinking that they would get bored
but he just gave them everything yeah
like and it was just it was it was so at
that point
zero i was hooked i knew i was hooked
because i just i was fascinated by it i
just couldn't [ __ ] believe that he
was the one who invented sonichu
yeah he said when he made songs yeah
like i could like because sonichu was
just
if you don't know what sonichu is
there's probably a picture of it on the
screen
yeah monstrosity massive meme right on
the internet and
for the longest time i saw that [ __ ]
everywhere yeah and i was just like
where did this come from
but now i know it's from the brilliant
mind of chris chan so thank you for uh
other good channels that do
documentaries there's a guy called toad
mckinley
and he did a two-part documentary on
like chris hansen
and that whole debacle it's really good
actually that was good um
how long are these documentaries because
i know you watched three hours more
documentaries than
like both of us combined yeah a lot of
documentaries you can leave on in the
background i feel like the
like watching juno the christian ones
like they're so long
and often it's basically playing a whole
audio clip for 20 minutes you
get you get the gist yeah
it's just a podcast about chris chan
with someone else narrating as yeah